- This is definitely gonna
be a different style vlog.
You're gonna see some cheering.
- [All] Yeah!
- You're gonna see maybe
a quiet moment or two.
- [All] Ooh.
(upbeat music)
("Thirsty" by JKKM)
- In the hotel room in Indie here,
Brian is coming in with
the biggest fuckin piece
of luggage I've ever seen.
- I've been here for a damn week.
- Nonetheless, big,
humongous day for Vayner
Sports Today vlog.
You been seeing some of the
stuff along the way today,
the DVs, we have five
corners in this draft,
they all are gonna hit
the combine right now,
obviously the team is extremely excited,
here with the agents Brian and Tommy.
We're here with the brains and the power,
we're here with the looks, so in general,
very exciting day for all of us here.
Most of the team's been here
in Indie for several days.
I got in late last
night, headed to London,
excited for the sneaker drop,
South by Southwest this weekend,
but this is definitely gonna
be a different style vlog.
You're gonna see some cheering,
you're gonna see maybe
a quiet moment or two.
We'll edit very carefully,
but nonetheless,
very excited for our guys, overall,
you know, just very
proud of the whole crew
and how hard they've worked over the last
eight to 12 weeks.
And then on a separate
note the marketing front
has been extremely exciting.
A lot of you guys have been interacting,
and so, we'll see what happens.
Big, big, big day for the firm.
("Thirsty" by JKKM)
I like how I finished my Tweet.
Doing for these kids what
agents should be doing.
(laughs)
- That's what you said?
- Yeah.
I'm getting very hammy.
There he is!
- Oh yeah!
- There he is.
- Tom Urie asked me last night
if I was nervous, I said no.
(finger snap)
Just hit me, like now I am
starting to (clap) like alright.
I'm fucking jump--
- I got a huge call
with (bleep) 10 o'clock.
(all laughing)
I'm so pissed, so pissed.
Feel like I am gonna miss some.
- We are gonna have a bunch
of guys in the same pool.
You know what I mean?
- Man, I am really
nervous about Josh's run.
- Super nervous.
- I just want it over with.
- He look great now.
- Lets go Josh.
- Come on!
- He's in those...
- Lets go baby, orange
sneakers, lets fucking go!
Lets go Josh.
- Come on baby.
(clapping)
Focus.
- Come on Josh.
- [Man] You notice a lot
of kids who are not happy
with the situation that I started.
But the reason I'm over here, there.
- Whoa, good start.
- Good start.
- Come on Josh!
(all cheering)
- Yeah Josh!
Lets go Josh!
Yeah Josh, lets go baby, 4.49!
- That's unofficial, it's unofficial.
- Unofficial.
- He's really good at predicting.
- This aint Tommy's first Combine.
- Nah, he could lose.
- It happens, right?
- Come on, lets go!
- You first start, it happens.
- Fuck!
("Thirsty" by JKKM)
This is classic not taking
human stuff into equation.
He's a loser.
No, no really!
- Yes!
- What, what?
I don't know.
- I don't have to baby him, yes!
- What'd he say?
That was your punch line?
- No, I had a conversation
that was a thing
between winners and losers.
- That's life.
- We're not allowed to be
having this conversation.
- I used to have some good definitions.
- I'll give you the best definition.
Excuses.
If you have excuses,
you're a fucking loser.
This way you can have
a conversation with him
and get no bad report.
Let me know, okay?
Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Alright.
- That's why I said to him,
he doesn't even know how
fast he is if you bet that.
- I actually don't know,
like AJ, what would you run?
- Like a 5.6.
- Okay.
I agree.
- He's been trying for it, for three days.
- I ran a 5.2 at age 20 or
something like that, so, 5.6/5.7.
- Who's faster, me or you?
You?
- I am slow.
- I am slow too man.
(laughing)
This is the reverse of every
conversation we have ever had.
- I have zero, zero confidence
in my top limit speed, zero.
- Yeah.
- I am much quicker than I am fast.
- What's the crafty drill?
That shows your craftiness.
'Cause I'm a crush that.
("Thirsty" by JKKM)
So we haven't shown a whole
lot of the rest of the day
but we met up with a bunch of the guys,
we were in an area where we couldn't film.
Now we rushed to the
airport because our flight
got delayed by three hours.
We'll try to get on it.
Good day, all-in-all, got a
little taste of the Combine.
AJV did his thing, got a lot of stuff.
Really, saw of the guys,
which is really the ROI.
And just excited for the draft.
Only seven weeks away.
- Probably all three of us.
- [Airline Woman] You
have three reservations
and none of them have a ticket.
- I understand.
- [Airline Woman] Yeah,
they're just an itinerary.
- Understood.
- [Airline Woman] So, I
can easily change this
to the earlier one but you
have to pay for a ticket.
- Yes, that's fine.
- The update is Babin's not fancy,
so since he was in
economy, not first class,
they wouldn't let him switch.
So I am going on the earlier flight.
See ya, baby Babi.
See ya.
- Bye.
Gary talked a bunch of
trash about me not making it
on this flight.
I made it.
("Thirsty" by JKKM)